some might say songbird is the worst
thing to happen
in 2020. i can't think of anything worse
everyone hates it they wish it never
happened and it's completely ruined what
was shaping up to be a pretty great year
me though it's more like a lockdown in
that it doesn't really go anywhere
you sat looking at the same boring
people pretty much the entire time
and when you do get out you realize
there's nothing else to really do
because your life was pretty crap
beforehand anyway
now if you're wanting some escapism
during the pandemic
why not watch a movie about the pandemic
that shows what life might be like
in 2024 like playstations and iphones
the virus has gone up and we're at
covert 23 which means
it's too old for our kelly now donald
trump is probably still banging on about
the election
and though pretty much everyone has been
fired daryl at least managed to keep his
job at dunder mifflin
we're gonna be breaking down the whole
movie but if this is your first time
here
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
now let's get into song turd song dude
okay so sanctuary is too soon the movie
and from the start it feels pretty
distasteful especially because
a lot of people are still dying due to
the disease and it ruined
pretty much everyone's life this year
luckily for me
youtube's still a big thing so everyone
just sits about watching that or simping
on women that look like a discount bell
delphine
without the delicious tasting bath water
now that brings us to our video sponsor
and for just 100 you can own some
delicious bath water
and subscribers to our channel get minus
one percent off by clicking the link in
the description and using the code
killer with fire
warning may have horrendous side effects
but hey at least you get to support the
channel and you won't have to watch the
movie
now a lot of things have happened this
year including toilet paper shortages
the election brexit tiger king and of
course dominic cummings taking an
hour-long drive to barnard castle
in order to test his eyesight there were
also several protests
conspiracy theories that rose up and the
burning of so many 5g towers that i had
to watch this crap fest in 480p
rather than tackling any of those issues
though sungbird
brushes it all to the side to follow
niko a delivery driver who's immune to
the virus
because of this he can travel throughout
the city and even leave
but he decides to stay behind for his
girlfriend who i
wouldn't mind giving her my pencil hey
you're having that
when her liter catches the airborne
transmission
nico sets out to find an immunity
bracelet so that he can save her before
the authorities arrive to transport her
to a queue zone
this is where people go to die probably
of boredom
after being part of this movie hey now
on the other side of this we joined
peter griffith
piper griffin played by demi moore her
daughter has an immunodeficiency
and therefore would die if she got the
virus but that seems pretty much the
case for everyone
so i don't see what the big fuss is i
mean yeah
people are gonna die but isn't that
inevitable
i was really hoping that we'd get a sort
of last of us or children of men's
situation here
where nico had to escort her out the
city due to his immunity
and we could see how the class system
worked and that the pandemic completely
flipped the positions of power
for example one could argue that the
people who are viewed as the lower
members of society
such as postmen shop workers and
delivery drivers
for this year they were seen as being
low skilled however
2020 flipped that on its head to where
they became the most valuable
it would have been great to see this
elite family relying on someone they
wouldn't have even given the time of day
to in the past
but nah sung bird completely ignores
that to tell you
a by the numbers plot that you can
probably guess five minutes into the
movie
as it progresses we learn that piper's
husband is actually using black market
bracelets in order to visit a girl
who just so happens to be a bit of a
songbird aren't ya however
she has been chatting with an afghan war
vet who just so happens to own his own
drone
now nico learns from daryl about the
griffins having these immunity bracelets
and
selling them on so he attempts to get
one but he's ambushed by a man named
holland and all his forces
luckily for the lad he's saved by a guy
who just so happens to pop up out of
nowhere
and then for some reason he decides to
hang around where where all the soldiers
are
instead of adding anything to the actual
plot what a guy
oh well thanks for signing your own
death certificate to save this complete
stranger
now it turns out that holland used to be
a bin man but after all those in his
company started dying
he naturally got promoted to the top job
because that's how corporate ladders
work
and they just give the job to anybody
who can fill in the position
as long as no one else hate interviews
holland is also after nico's girlfriend
sarah and he travels to a home
captures her and waits for him to show
up he does he does the old
we're not so different you and i you
should join me and we could rule this
city
i think i don't know i was pretty far
into a game of candy crush at that point
but
he tries to persuade him round nico
doesn't want to do this though and when
he's backed into a corner
he grabs our plot device from earlier
and manages to kill him
where a [ __ ] pencil
luckily no one cares about murder in
2024
and no repercussions ever come from this
and even at the end
nico's never held to account for killing
a high-ranking member of society
similarly smells smell fiend and yes i'm
very immature
she's attacked by william aka piper's
husband
but luckily she's saved by her sims
drone who shoots him whilst he's going
after her
again no one cares about murder anymore
so nothing ever comes from this
probably put that down as a culvert
death now before sarah reaches the q
zone nico manages to catch up to her and
he slaps an immunity bracer on her wrist
at the last second
to save her from being escorted away
this is pretty stupid
because throughout the movie they've
made it very clear that if you're
outside without one of these bracelets
then you're pretty much dead so you
would have thought that
they would have checked sarah's wrist
for one several several several times
but i guess not as
no one questions why all of a sudden she
has one the second after her boyfriend
touched her wrist
this virus must make people really
stupid as well together the pair leave
the city and ride off into the sunset
however the world's pretty much ruined
either way and it's doubtful that
they're gonna have anything to look
forward to
as it's all gone to hell so hey just
just like real life oh my oh my god this
movie is so real
now before we get into our review if
you're one of the two people that are
still enjoying this video then please
drop a thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns like this every
day
we're giving away three free copies of
the lord of the rings 4k box set
aka good movies to people who are
following the channel
i'll talk about that at the end of the
video now as for songbird
i don't think it's a conspiracy theory
at this point that i thought it was
absolutely atrocious my jokes have been
pretty bad throughout this
and they were still in better taste than
a movie trying to capitalize on one of
the most depressing things in recent
memory
you can tell they just threw this
together as quickly as possible
and it's doubtful that the film even had
more than one draft as the scripts been
rushed out
with little care or any thought into the
concept and what they could really do
with it
this had the potential to let us examine
the last year
and also discuss why we feel so divided
when we first went into lockdown i
thought we'd finally found something
that we could all be in together over
however that hasn't been the case at all
and you could argue that we're
completely separated at this point in
terms of political and civil views
rather than discussing or analyzing any
of that though
songbird instead takes a stale old
concept
in which your boy is trying to rescue
his girlfriend and simply applies it to
the pandemic
in my opinion this should have been the
other way around where the pandemic was
actually the thing driving the plot
the characters don't have the depth to
them that they should have and the film
is devoid of any real fun there was an
amazing opportunity to try and do
something like the dawn of the dead
shopping scene where we could have
watched nico basically getting the keys
to the kingdom
and having fun with his immunity however
that's all completely missing
and the movie just feels like one missed
opportunity after another
maybe michael bay the king of subtlety
wasn't the right person to be tackling
the pandemic because it just feels so
surface level that it doesn't really add
any social commentary or depth to what
we see
i'm aware i'm ranting here but yeah not
a good film
however it isn't really the actor's
fault i don't think
as everyone does a good job with what
they have i'm not having to go at them
as you know they did they did whatever
they could with that
that worst script it's just a script the
damn
script is so so bad it just makes you
think
why was this even made it's in poor
taste but even if you brush that to the
side
the story doesn't do enough to justify
its existence
sung bad was pretty bad and in a yeah
devoid of movies
i feel like this might actually be its
worst i can't really recommend it
and it gets a 2 out of 10. now don't
forget that on the 30th of december
we're giving away three copies of the
lord of the rings 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the film
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button
below and as a thank you
you get videos like this early now if
you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the what if trailer which
will be linked on screen now
we go over the entire thing so it's
definitely worth checking out
if you want to know more anyway with
that other way thank you for sitting
through the video
i've been paul the complete idiot i'll
see you next time
take care peace